it's always a joy to watch an anime
protagonist unleash a key ability for
the first time the impact of the scenes
and how these abilities change the name
of the game are just unbelievable and
i'd like to share some of my favorites
for today's list but hey before we begin
i'd like to give a quick shout out to
the sponsors of this video world flipper
a much welcome addition to the scigames
library world flipper brings something
new and exciting to the table as it
combines the thrilling action of pinball
with various rpg elements ever wondered
how pinball must feel if you add things
like skills heroes and boss raids into
the mix well you don't have to look any
further than world flipper as in
tradition world flipper features an
extensive array of collectible heroes
and weapons make sure to collect them
all and you can even melt weapons in
order to equip their abilities to even
more powerful ones so how's that for
customization so what are you waiting
for pre-register now pre-register today
and receive amazing rewards like a
four-star eraser and load star beads
world flippers in-game currency players
can also pre-register via the app store
and google play for additional perks too
links in the description come and join
the fun now without further ado let's
take a deep dive into some of the most
iconic awakening scenes in anime we
start out with a moment from fate
unlimited blade works shiro's projection
[Music]
a lot of these awakenings happen in the
clutch when our heroes are in a bind
it's either that or moments when our
heroes finally steal his resolve and
decided to finally do away with all the
emotional burdens that plagued him this
is more of the former where shiro and
rin find themselves completely
outmatched in battle against kuzuki
shiro couldn't have picked a better time
to whip out one of the coolest abilities
in the main fate timeline too being able
to copy and materialize weapons has
always been a favorite of mine as far as
abilities are concerned and seeing it
here in action just feels really cool it
resulted in an intense battle that's a
preview of things to come just wait
until the latter fights when shiro
pushes himself past the limits of this
ability and starts tracing more insane
attacks yep shiro will have more epic
battles to show off the true
capabilities of this ability but the
first awakening does carry with it a
sense of nostalgia when i look back
let's get to a moment similar to the
previous one where our heroes are in a
bind always count on attack on titan to
have an epic season finale that will be
remembered for years to come so for
season two that would come in the form
of eren already an enigma full of
surprises releasing a new power on a
more humorous note though he also
indirectly blocked magasta's advances
before doing it yes the ship has never
had a chance well yet this ability is
truly what an awakening in anime should
be a complete game changer that pretty
much rewrites the tempo and the rules of
the world that we as the audience have
grown accustomed to who knew that aaron
out of all the characters would have
access to such an amazing power it's
also a preview for things to come and
those who have watched the latest
episodes of attack on titan or finished
reading the manga can attest to that
unleashing his demon form makes its way
to the number eight spot
now here's a moment to remember for
black clover fans most of the time i
spent time on this channel talking about
yummy or the black balls in general but
if you're going to trim things down to
ask the only moment you can see that he
does have one hell of a highlight real
all for himself with one of my favorite
entries being his first demon form
appearance this moment comes pretty deep
into the series run when he's left
facing off against insurmountable office
in the form of land ross by this point
we've seen arsenal be a badass quite a
number of times already but did you
expect him to go beyond and show off
this chilling form of his the internal
monologue that set up this moment is all
sorts of epic too and we get treated to
one insane ass kicking afterwards after
slow walk through the flames is truly a
shining moment some people have
complained about the animation in this
sequence however and i think that those
criticisms aren't unfounded nonetheless
this awakening is so cool that i can't
help but include it here
at seven is gold experience requiem
talk about a power-up coming just at the
right time diorno's gold experience
evolving into gold experience requiem is
probably my most hyped moment in golden
wind next to the seven page mudder of
course this awakening came in really
clutch just as diavalo pretty much
destroyed giorno and gold experience
with his overwhelming power however
there's just something wrong as far as
the dastardly villains concerned he just
can't finish the job just as he moves in
to deal the final blow the arrow goes
into gold experience allowing it to move
to the next stage of evolution diablo
finding out that he was screwed was a
complete joy to watch it's these kinds
of mid-battle revelations in the most
crucial of moments leading to an epic
turnaround in a brand new form that give
me goosebumps and make me love shonen
anime tropes
sixth in line is what people call
ichigo's vasto lord former
to be fair ichigo had two candidates
that are viable for this list it was
either his first bankai or this one
while the bankai is all sorts of awesome
and i think that his fight with biakuya
is one of the best ones the series has
to offer this one just felt a bit more
surreal both are game changers during
the series but this true hollow form was
the one that evoked emotions that are
more than just excitement and thrill
there's something very ominous about
this form and it's not just in the
intimidating appearance for the very
first time we see ichigo in a state
where he's lost control of everything
with his full power unleashed he makes
short work of all kiyora and then turns
on people he considered friends the
level of ruthlessness here is so unlike
ichigo and it's a result of the hollow
in him finally taking full control it's
a truly scary sight to behold that
actually pushes boundaries that we never
thought could be crossed before
next in line is naruto's transformation
against pain
in a lot of ways the pain fighting
naruto marks a checkpoint a landmark
that we'll always talk about when
discussing naruto as a whole it's the
fight that i feel had the highest stake
so far for the greatest number of
characters and it was also the fight
that made everyone recognize naruto for
the hero that he was however let's talk
about the actual battle when naruto
finally whips out this sick looking form
for the very first time it all started
with hinata seemingly getting killed for
naruto to start throwing those forms one
after another this is probably the most
savage we've ever seen naruto so far and
people thought that pain would be
overwhelmed but it's not to be yet but
it did lead to a touching moment with
his father where we get to learn more
about the background of the world
overall a great scene and a moment that
came out of this amazing fight we march
on with our last pre-top three entry
tanjiro's hinoka mikagura
ah the moment that broke the internet i
remember it like it was just yesterday
and i think that you'd agree that this
really does belong on this list demon
slayer has had its share of deserving
moments zenitsu's badass scene in the
same arc included but none had the
amount of cultural impact as this one
did one can easily pass this off as
animation and aren't making the scene as
right after it's airing people wouldn't
stop talking about ufo table in the
animation however if you can ask me an
underrated part of this scene is the
music i think the music and animation
come together to present a scene to be
as epic as possible and here you can see
exactly that in play it couldn't have
been placed better too it ends the
episode capping off what was the
toughest boss fight our heroes had to
deal with so far it left the audiences
in a complete high and the next day
demon slayer was the talk of the town
probably one of the most successful
awakening scenes in terms of taking what
the manga has and going a way further
with it
for our number three we look at luffy's
conquerors hakim
one piece is marine foot arc is notable
for many things for me i'll always
remember it for the first major display
of luffy's conqueror's haki yep it's not
the first display of luffy's haki
technically speaking our protagonist
first gave hints about the ability in
his battle against motobaro where it was
able to send dual's pet running however
this is the first display of the
abilities prowess on such a large scale
and in a crucial setting it was able to
mow down an entire army allowing him the
opening to try and save ace
and right after that we have probably my
most talked about moment in hunter
hunter hey i can't help it it's truly
one of the most goosebump inducing
moments in the 2011 series gone's battle
against beethoven is undoubtedly my
favorite among all of them and he gave
the world its first glimpse of adult
gone i know i often put emphasis on gone
discarding his emotions in the
eye-widening black and white scene so it
can't be helped that adagon himself has
gotten a bit overlooked however for
today how about we take a look at how
awesome adolgon looked it's the peak
potential of his men and physical
abilities manifested as both a scary and
awe-inspiring form that pushed this
scene to be one of the best hunter
hunter had to offer
[Music]
[Applause]
topping the list is goku's first ultra
instinct
[Music]
now you might know what ultra instinct
is but let's look back at the epic
battle between goku and jiren it's an
episode that's preceded by a lot of hype
and with the way the fight went i'm
certain that the battle did end up
living up to it throughout the fight we
see goku getting trounced really he does
get some offensive but jiren seems to be
in full control of the battle having a
counter for everything our protagonist
does and then
this happens the ultra instinct mode
that promptly turns the fight around
it's a triumphant moment to remember
dragon ball super 4 and it will live in
every dragon ball fans hearts the
succeeding pummeling that goku gives is
such a sight to watch what i like about
this moment is that it was one that gave
us the purest sense of triumph whereas
most of the other awakenings mentioned
came as a result of a desperation
situation unlocking some newfound power
you can clearly see goku building up for
the big moment throughout the fight it's
a power that he had yet he had to master
but we all knew it was coming in this
very fight when it did happen it felt
well earned
[Applause]
[Music]
and that wraps up the list and i hope
you enjoyed the video those are my top
10 awakenings and i wonder whether you
agree with these picks or not if you had
a great time watching this video please
let me know in the comment section and
do check out the channel's other
countdown videos too we've got loads and
loads of them if you're up for
supporting the channel in a more direct
manner my patreon and channel
memberships are open too so do check
those out as well don't forget to check
out our sponsors game world flipper
check the link in the description and
come and join the fun that's gonna be it
for today i wish you a great day and
i'll see you soon in the next video
[Music]
you